yeah exactly i feel like having a good
balance is the healthy thing because
um you have to find this balance between
knowing that you can't please
everyone um and finding a balance
between okay this this this person's
making a legitimate point
i i can change my behavior because you
know he yeah they
they're making a sound argument and i
completely understand i'm in a comment
section full of yes men is just
kind of boring isn't it that's a reason
well i mean you know people have that
you know when
i read comments about trash days i'll be
like i [ __ ] hate joe or i [ __ ]
hate connor yeah right and i'm like well
i mean i get it right because it's like
i guess to us
for like characters that's fine it's all
good dude
you've got your favorite i get it it's
all good dude
[Music]
yeah i don't know it's it's but then but
sometimes they go a little too far with
it like man i wish connor would you
[ __ ] quit the podcast
like i'm sorry that's not gonna happen
anytime it's not gonna happen but like
if it did do you really
do you think everyone wants that yeah
like i don't know there are some that
are just like man i wish connor would
just
deck gaunt in the faces
is this how friends act you know at
least wait till the trash tastes special
where we
like to have a boxing match or something
like that not that we have anything
planned and that was just me so we're
going to get boxing
boxing match confirmed confirmed i'd
actually like unironically
love to be like a youtuber boxing match
because i just think like one
bayleen's like getting ideas right now
it's like multi-million dollar day
i wish i could bring in
multi-millionaire i i don't know because
like
one you get an excuse to train you could
probably hire a personal coach you know
yeah i'd probably get in mad shape for
that and it would probably be fun i
guess i'll play the villain i'd love
that that'd be so much fun
but who would i fight though you know
that's the thing right yeah i haven't
got any enemies
so i should start beef with someone now
stop flexing
what do you want is not having enemies
like something to brag about like man
conor doesn't
god kind of just hate anyone i mean i
don't even ask for enemies and i have
enemies
i mean enemies are very strong world
yeah there's probably some people who
dislike me
but like i i don't have any like open
beef with anyone on youtube
right i mean i don't really [ __ ] do
anything i just kind of just
do my own thing i mean there's a
difference between having youtuber beef
and having actual real beef where you
have a big problem with someone yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was like would you what
would you
categorize like the ksi logan paul stuff
would you just pure youtube beef or like
legit that has to be youtube beef right
it was so over the top i mean i don't
like i think they're hating each other
yeah and i think along the way they
started liking it
yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty sure it
started as legitimate beef and then they
were like hold on
we can make money off we're making tens
of millions of dollars
hold on hold the phone i mean i feel
like the line is blurred where
you have a financial incentive to have
beef oh yeah yeah
if they're like if they're just like
[ __ ] talking to each other and twisting
the light bulb like in on over mailings
head right now just like
lighting up bro she's like she has a pog
face right now she's like
cause they made they made like over like
what twenty thirty million dollars each
yeah yeah like that because it's not
it's not actually beef like personal
beef about anything that
really matters like no one told like one
of their moms to go [ __ ] themselves
or like oh you know like it was like
yeah the insults were
dude the [ __ ] uh the pre-match [ __ ]
like beef like [ __ ] talking things were
the best part of the boxing matches
they were so bad at talking [ __ ] to each
other it was like
it was like wrestling
my dad is nintendo yeah like my dad
knows shigeru miyamoto
my dad my dad's goku
and he's got the dream it's just like
yeah watching watching
if you didn't give a [ __ ] about any
youtube boxing it was quite entertaining
as much as uh it was entertaining to
watch us like i paid for the
pay-per-view because i'm like you know
what
if i if i can if you can make this a
thing on youtube i'm i'm more i
i paid for it because i'm just like you
know what you are making entertainment i
i [ __ ] get that i i'm
i'm watching a clown fiesta and i'm
watching to i'm paying to watch the
circus but i'll pay to watch the circus
you know
no and i i want more of this i think
this is great for youtube and also
for boxing it did like wonders yeah and
it was like it's like the whole like the
renaissance of boxing right well i mean
for
like the people in our age
my dad loves boxing and my dad's age
bracket love boxing
yeah they love it but like you know
under under 30 and i think
mid 30s [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about boxing
yeah a lot of people don't i mean i'm
sure there is a
there's a good there's a good segment of
people who probably love boxing and mma
and all that yeah but it wasn't like
nearly as popular as it used to be
with our age group at least yeah yeah
because boxing was like
you know some of the most classic
moments in sports and boxing matches
like anything
like rumble in the jungle you know
anything with muhammad iconic
[ __ ] iconic to this day and you know
i i grew up in an era where
i didn't even watch any boxing match i
don't think i don't i didn't watch
boxing i don't think i've ever sat down
and watched a boxing match in my life i
i would just
my dad loved watching it and he'd be
like man this guy's fighting this guy
for the world heavyweight and i'm like
who are these two people no no because
if you're a kid and your parents weren't
into it
then how the [ __ ] can you afford to
watch the pay-per-view yeah right like
there's there's no way you could watch
in it's always in american time so it's
always that like
3 a.m like sky which is already like 40
pounds a month and you pay an extra 20
pounds on top to get the pay-per-view
yeah yeah yeah i was crazy yeah i mean
i i don't know it's like uh what do you
think about the whole uh i don't know
this is changing gears too fast but uh
we think about the whole
thing where everyone's like man they're
they're ruining like boxing by bringing
in these influences to it because it's
happening with chess as well uh by
bringing in these like non-traditions
where you bring in like you know you
kind of i guess
the way they would argue is like you're
diluting like the sport right
like i don't unders i don't understand
how
putting more eyes onto a sport ruins it
yeah because the whole point
of keeping a sport alive is that
a sport is kept alive by how many
viewers watch it
yeah i mean there's there's a side of it
where i can understand
like you know for chess like at least
you know what if you start at age 12
right and then you're like you're like
30 now you're a grandmaster you've
literally been playing your whole life
for chess right
you're about to like this is your time
to shine and then [ __ ] pogchamps has
like
you know 20 30 times more viewers than
anything you ever will get
i i could i could understand why they're
mad yeah right that just sounds like
that just sounds like a villain
protagonist too some sports have yeah i
understand why
i've been in backstory to some sports
anime right it's super easy to
understand
why they would get mad but then you know
if you like anyone it's like a youtube
video right if i make a youtube video
and i'm a small youtuber
right about um about this mike wazowski
figure
right right and then gone you know who
has
you know a million uh let's say gonna
say ghana's
three million right and a youtuber ten
thousand makes a video about mike
wazowski and gone
pretty much does like nearly a one for
one video you know but in god's style
right yes that guy will be angry he's
like god just made my video but to a
bigger audience he's gonna get all the
views
what you're not seeing is a huge kick
that you're gonna get a bunch of
trickle-down views yeah of course and
that's what's going to happen
with all the stuff is that yeah you're
not going to see the immediate results
of
you know getting the trickle-down effect
from all these massive events with like
normies if you will right but they but i
think the problem is that most of these
like
quantum coil purists don't see it as a
trickle-down effect they just no no i
don't know
they see it as like sloppy seconds right
well yeah they see it as like you're
ruining the sanctity of my sport it's
like i wanted all the guys to come to me
first yeah yeah yeah but you know it's
you know again more eyes more sponsor
money it's all good